[Music]
his actions were
nothing short of heroic many more people
would have died last night if not for a
responsible armed citizen
police praising the heroic actions of a
good guy with a gun who neutralized a
deranged shooter at a mall in indiana it
took elijah dicken just 15 seconds to
take down the suspect who just shot and
killed three people and injured two
others the 22 year old going toward and
confronting the shooter who was trying
to hide while ushering people to safety
but liberals say his actions were way
out of line arguing this hero should not
even be called a good samaritan
oh and then there's the ladies of the
view
but with this good samaritan thing
listen i was trained when i was at the
justice department in firearms and i was
trained in defensive firearm training it
is very hard to hit a moving target it
is hard for people that are trained to
hit a moving target it is very lucky
that that good samaritan hit that moving
target in that way and he wasn't he had
a gun permit but he wasn't supposed to
be in the mall with a gun so he broke
the law even though he was a guy even
though he was uh
you're saying no no no judges he didn't
break the law
he didn't break the law they say in the
mall they don't want you to have a gun
what law did he break he didn't break
any law what he did was he came to the
defense of another person i'm surprised
at you sonny you worked in the for the
department of justice okay here we go
ideology is trumping the murder of
innocent victims they are so left that
they say they want to believe that it's
a horrible thing and god forbid we call
this person a good samaritan who stops a
mass shooter because he's a law-abiding
guy with a permit for a gun and she's
upset that he stopped the killer
what is wrong with this picture
that's all i have to say there's nothing
else to say
do you uh do you want a layup jessica
i'll ask you here's the layup
opportunity is this guy a good samaritan
sure he killed the mass shooter who
still managed to also kill three people
before this happened which is a pretty
big deal and we shouldn't lose focus on
that it does seem that he bought his
guns legally he bought them back in
march
he didn't have an adult record but he
did have a juvenile record i don't know
what role that could play going forward
in terms of holding people back from
getting the judges nodding along with me
so that's a good sign
but i think
what is important to not lose sight of
and this happens as new news stories
roll in then people push out the old
ones and this happens to on both sides
that now it's a good one a good guy with
a gun can help this two days ago it was
400 trained cops let you know 20 kids
die in classrooms while they were
waiting around twiddling their thumbs
and using hand sanitizer yeah i wish
this guy was in uvalde oh he sure
if he wants to sign up and do a better
job than those police officers i would
welcome him to do that but it still is a
sorry reflection on the state of america
that it's an average day that three
people are murdered by someone we are
lucky that someone took him out but that
doesn't mean that we don't have a
tremendous gun problem in this country
yeah we are lucky and i think they
pulled this stain and and people trust a
regular citizen with a gun sometimes
even more than police officers because
police officers they're few and far
between if there's a civilian right
there during the shooting they're going
to be able to neutralize that shooter
like that and who were the the first
people to call him a hero were the cops
because it took 11 minutes after the
9-1-1 call for the police to get there
exactly and
the local news agency there wthr want to
give them credit they approached several
gun instructors and they said how
difficult would it be for this to
replicate this and this
dicken put out eight out of ten shots on
target in 15 seconds at almost double
the maximum pistol range distance nobody
else could do that they were they said
they don't even come close so i think
one
hero also would you please join the navy
seals that's a good shot that's for sure
greg gutfeld well um uh jessica brought
up the the news cycle and she's right
about how people
one side goes with their story and
another side brings up their story
but the problem is that other story the
texas story and all the other matches
get massively amplified this story must
be amplified because it's clear that was
a copycat shooter right these are all
happening in clumps because the
amplification of the previous shootings
so it stands to reason if you were to
amplify this story
that would give copycats you know second
a second thought right it's like at the
uncertainty that there might be an armed
person around there in the place that
you want to go light up and might take
you out that might help so more of these
stories i would love to hear and i'd
love to hear them you know uh on in the
media but i doubt that this is showing
up on cnn or msnbc gun control zealots
will say permit to carry doesn't reduce
incidents of mass shootings well this
one didn't reduce the incident it
reduced the severity what does that
sound like
vaccines right think of this like a
vaccine the permit to carry didn't
prevent the contagion right but it
diminished the harm dramatically so
you're going to you're going to say you
don't want it now this is
and it goes back to the sunny hostage
she made in her
in her best case i can't believe she
would have preferred to have more
victims but that's what she's basically
saying i mean you just have to in what
is the alternate in that alternative in
that reality in a mass shooter to say
i'm glad that guy wasn't there to stop
it lastly this is very hard to compare
to something like uh what the tragedy in
texas because the reason why this
private citizen legally armed was able
to shoot so quickly didn't have to wait
for approval there was no red tape there
was no violation of protocol that's the
thing that they got to look at why were
400 people there and no one were able to
do it but this kid could do it because
he wasn't them and you know what's
interesting in one more point is is the
fact that um when when
she says that sunny hostin says well you
know you have to be really good to do
that he could have killed a lot of
people that's always the argument on the
other side he could have killed a lot
but he didn't let's deal with the facts
he didn't he didn't he's a great shot
and that was a great analogy about the
vaccines
did not prevent the contagion all right
coming up hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else